on en vient maintenant à cette
information qu'il faut encore vous
donner au conditionnel puisque elle n'a
pas reçu ce soir de confirmation
officielle
nicolas et cécilia sarkozy aurait engagé
une procédure pour officialiser leur
séparation
interrogé sur le sujet l'elysée elle n'a
souhaité faire aucun commentaire
l'absence de cécilia sarkozy au côté de
son époux depuis plusieurs semaines
avait bien sûr fait naître des doutes
ce serait en tout cas une première sous
la vème république véronique sainte
olive sylvain débat depuis des semaines
les journaux alimente la rumeur d'une
séparation des époux sarkozy
en effet la dernière apparition publique
de cécilia sarkozy remonte au 14 juillet
dernier sur le perron de l'elysée
absente de toutes les cérémonies
officielles elle est absente aussi en
bulgarie lorsque le président sir en
deux mois après la libération des
infirmières
pourtant chaque fois qu'il est interrogé
le porte parole de l'elysée oppose la
même réponse aucun commentaire sur ces
questions mais ce matin sur son site le
nouvel observateur va plus loin il
affirme que la séparation serait
consommée comment est ce que vous avez
eu cette information et nous avons eu
cette information lundi soir par un
informateur
s'ils étaient manifestement avec le
couple ou avec madame sarkozy ou en tout
cas en ligne directe avec elle les
pratiquement je dirais en temps réel
c'est vrai que cette source est proche
de madame sarkozy
et c'est vrai que donc ça semblerait
indiquer que c'est elle qui souhaitait
que cette information soit rendue
publique
la vie politique continue mais dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée on ne parle que
de cela
il apparaît que le président la
république connaît aujourd'hui
et productive est possible sans aucune
époque politique parce qu'il a gravi les
échelons du pouvoir avec avec ses causes
le seul qui a commenté sa vie privée se
soit lui-même
nicolas sarkozy lui enchaîne sa journée
comme si de rien n'était rendez vous
avec le président irakien puis avec le
président grec
cet après midi discours au conseil
économique et social sur la lutte contre
la pauvreté
mais les questions sur sa situation
personnelle sont plus que jamais mal
venu